ce risque de sombrer nes ou a fait des
années que les autochtones réclament une
enquête sur les femmes disparues ou
assassinées pour faire la lumière sur
cette crise qui sévit dans leur
communauté
des enquêtes ont été menées tant bien
que mal et en 2014 finalement de la grc
annonçait un chiffre officiel 1200
femmes autochtones disparues ou
assassinées 10 et elles en conférence de
presse
le gouvernement conservateur n'en a pas
fait une priorité
pas de commission denquête pas d'
enquêtes plus poussées sur ce chiffre
inquiétant tragique même le mystère
persiste encore aujourd'hui sur le
nombre réel de victimes sur la qualité d
enquête de la grc et d'autres corps
policiers
ce que nous avons dit la ministre des
affaires autochtones c'est que la
situation est bien plus tragique qu'on
ne pense la ministre bennett a rencontré
des familles et recueilli des
témoignages elle ne veut pas avancer de
chiffres mais il y en a qui circulent
4000 femmes autochtones assassinées ou
disparues dit la ministre de la
condition féminine
elle cite une enquête menée par un
groupe de militants autochtones qui
avait rapporté leurs conclusions au
gouvernement conservateur
en vain un chiffre qui ne peut pas être
confirmé mais qui reste plausible disent
certains c'est ce que ça change de
tomber à 1200 à 4 minskikh là pour moi
c'est que
le message qu'on lance depuis 20 ans
enfin les gens vont comprendre que ces
pots pourriez et les familles des
victimes ne veulent pas baisser les bras
nous avons entendu des histoires de
femme disparue il ya 50 ou 75 ans dit la
ministre
devrait-on aller aussi loin et ce n'est
pas tout ça - d'achat tryba camarades
qu'il ya des morts que la police a
classé comme des suicides qui pourraient
être des assassinats dit la ministre
comme le cas d'une femme dont le corps a
été retrouvé les mains liées derrière le
dos le gouvernement joyce avance vers
une enquête nationale mais on le voit
c'est un processus une mission qui
s'annonce extrêmement difficile à 7 ou
tunisio céline que ces données ce
gouvernement de faire la lumière sur
cette affaire
les conservateurs eux étaient au courant
mais ont décidé de ne pas se lancer dans
cette aventure
une enquête nationale sera mis sur pied
les libéraux y met l'argent et les
effectifs il l'avait promis d'ailleurs
les membres n'ont pas encore été choisi
et cette enquête se donne deux ans pour
faire son travail un travail très
difficile on le voit dès maintenant par
exemple
devra-t-on rouvrir des enquêtes
criminelles à la lumière de ce qu'on a
pu apprendre à et bien il semble que oui
et des exemples inquiétants sont
nombreux des enquêtes bâclées ou des
enquêtes criminelles qui n'ont jamais
été ouverte
faute d'effectifs policiers ou de
volonté des témoignages qui de toute
évidence n'ont pas été pris en compte
des indices qui n'ont pas été suivis
sans parler de ces cas de soi disant
suicide qu'il en était pas alors est
comment faire ce travail d' enquête
maintenant après des années et même des
décennies
c'est un défi et à travail de longue
haleine céline oui jusqu'où on va
remonter merci joyce au revoir au revoir
je
où